Rossi Ross Matthew hi Drew hi everybody
hi it is fun to hit the headlines and we
have a very special guest at the desk
he's a comedian with 5 million Tick Tock
followers who counts Kevin Hart as a
mentor and Drake as a friend please
welcome
Drewsky
[Applause]
meet Drew ski you're the real Jews well
people used to call me drewski when I
was a kid oh no they did absolutely Drew
bear Drew ski absolutely you know my
government name is actually d-r-e-w just
like yours yes and by the way I just
need to tell you know I know you're
gonna
You're Gonna Want to take my clothes off
and put your clothes on because your
outfit is just giving me life I thought
I had the worst outfit
[Applause]
I'm making it don't oh no I this is like
you have you've got mad style and I want
it thank you so much all right well
first up Insider reports Nicholas Cage
was so committed to playing Dracula in
the new movie Renfield he shaved his
teeth down so his vampire veneers would
fit more snugly and not impede his
speech and he also spent up to three and
a half hours in hair and makeup each day
to be fitted with his head to toe
Dracula Prosthetics this is so Nicholas
Cage right thoughts like don't you guys
ever undergo a physical change for
anything you wouldn't do this not even
for a roll you could really sink your
teeth I'm big on the method but I'm not
shaving my teeth down to do that I ain't
gonna lie no I'm not doing this I'm not
a chance no no I'd have to take some
time to really chew on it I really would
if they came to it said the role of a
lifetime you just got to shave your
teeth down you wouldn't even think about
it well no I might do that I might do
that yes yeah it just depends on what it
is you know what I'm saying if they
bring back uh Space Jam three yeah I
might do that they bring back Space Jam
free so let's clap it up
with it we've got Michael Jordan Bugs
Bunny and a filer
all right next up the New York Post
reports men are a mess when it comes to
Skin Care a study conducted by one poll
reveals 33 of gen Z and Millennial men
don't have a skin care routine and half
of the guys who were pulled would rather
go out on a bad date or go to a doctor's
appointment than be bothered with their
skin care all right first tell us yes
drewski you got good skin yes yeah
what's your routine or do you have one
well I wash my face as much as I was my
hindsight so uh yeah that's a good
skincare let's type it up for that
[Applause]
I'm big on like you know the products
they have like the two in one three in
one right you want efficient yeah I'm
kind of like I'll do it but I want the
product and the product I ain't gonna
get all the separate products like all
the women I'm gonna get the three and
one the four and one is there any man
here who does have a skin care routine
hello
yes thank you there's a man up in the
back
just out of curiosity what are you doing
what's your name and who are you
hi Drew my name is Jake
um I'm a college student here and for my
skincare routine I just do like the
basic you know like cleanser I do some
um serums as well moisturizer I also
have like something that's prescripted
by my doctor because I've had bad acne
scars ever since I've hit puberty so um
just taking it one day at a time really
it's if you feel good it's like a
pick-me-up I love that you said you just
do the basics and you're like lotion
serum prescription
um but so you know good for you gotta
take care if I could go back and tell
myself anything it'd be SPF and put that
pizza down you know like those are the
two things can I ask you a question has
since you've done skin care like does it
make you feel better about yourself like
more empowered in your day or do you
just think it's you know a box to check
and moving on don't think about it yeah
that's a great question
um you know my skin has always been a
big insecurity especially studying
screen acting at my school there's this
big
um can like big narrative that we have
to look perfect on screen
um but taking it day by day it makes me
feel good
um even when I don't feel so good but
I'm just doing something to take care of
myself
um and a little goes a very long way you
are so gosh darn well spoken
well we're not better than me man I'm
still using three of them
oh my God I love you guys all right we
have to go to a quick commercial break
we'll be right back with some more news
[Music]